congratulations you're expecting a
little boy
how are you doing how are you feeling
i'm good
i mean i'm swollen and i'm tired
i like to eat i like to take a lot of
naps
i'm 41 and i'm doing it so
you know i feel really lucky and yeah
it's wild it's still very surreal to me
it truly feels like the most important
thing that i will ever do in my life
like nothing else
matters you know so everything just
changes in your life the way that i used
to
stress about other things and i'm like
well that doesn't matter anymore and
like and it can't because he'll come
first
is this something that you always wanted
and did
you think it would happen that this was
meant for you oh yeah no i did
i mean it was something i always wanted
and i'd been married before i didn't
think i'd ever get married again
and i sort of i've suffered from enough
anxiety over it so i kind of got to this
place of like i have to just
give in and you know if it's meant to be
it's meant to be
i went away in august to work on a film
and i thought i had jet lag
for a while but it wasn't
i was driving to work every day but i'd
be like crying
work i'd be like bawling on the freeway
like
but i just thought oh i'm such an
emotional person and just like
processing things all the time
yes feel those feelings i can't thank
you enough
for being so open and transparent you
know using the platform that you have to
talk about how
you know it's not all sunshine and roses
and rainbows that you
you know you were very open about some
of the hurdles that you experienced
along the way yeah would you just share
some of those obstacles that you
encountered and like
how did they maybe help you get to where
you are today you know i'm being
considered as such
because i'm 40 but i don't feel 40 and
like what is 40. i had a
a doctor who i absolutely love but it
was just sort of like
the routine it was like the protocol
to be like well if you're not here at
this point like then that's what
you're defined as and it's never going
to happen
one of the biggest things the biggest
gifts that he gave me when i
came back from filming in august was he
said i'm so happy that you trusted in
your body
that you listened to your body and that
just meant the world to me because
it spent so much time doubting it and
having like emotional breakdowns over it
thinking like oh well you know it's all
over and it wasn't
to see you sitting here smiling glowing
you know your baby boy is coming how are
you preparing are you into
have you made a nursery where are you
guys at with that yeah yeah
i still have uh my books i'm getting
through
we've set up uh our little nursery i
mean we're just doing it
moment by moment lots of like anxiety
attacks
over what oh this is like terrifying but
for me personally
i've always i've been processing the the
surrealism is around like i never
thought anything like this would happen
for me and like now it's happening
like what does that mean and like oh my
god i'm gonna be a mom
and like how do i be a good mom it's
just new
it's i think it's it's uh it's like that
first-time mom
craziness or just like i don't know what
i'm doing but i feel
really lucky that i have a great group
of women i have an amazing midwife and
doula
and i already have postpartum doulas
that i'm talking to
and so are you going natural home birth
homeopathic
style that is my plan
wow that's my plan but you know that's
what i hoped for
but i really just rely on
my midwife i mean she's like my my
center
i've actually known her since uh i was
16.
they're very grounding for me and like
it's okay it's normal you know when i
call and i'm like
you know yeah i know you're a very
passionate person i know you're very
dedicated to you know animal
rights i'm curious as your you know your
son you know grows up and becomes a
little man what are some of the
qualities
that you and your husband are hoping to
instill in him oh gosh
i mean i just want to help raise
a loving aware
sensitive conscious human being
i just want to give him the opportunity
to experience
all the magic in the world
and practice his empathy you know in
consideration of others
you are absolutely delivering with your
latest film
don't tell a soul and what i think it's
so interesting is that
this is not you know vampires and
monsters and a slasher movie this is a
movie that's absolutely like grounded in
in reality i'm stuck down here i cannot
get out by myself that man
is someone else's problem no we can't
just leave him there you boys are
quiet today not getting along
it's definitely one of those stories
that you kind of think it's one thing
and then it turns into another it's
constantly
um surprising you and you know
challenging you in
some new way the role of carolyn was
very heavy
for sure and it was a huge
transformation becoming her
and really stepping into that world i
feel so helpless with you boys
okay
i'm so used to seeing the glamorous
mina suvari in movies and on the red
carpet
seeing you in this character where she's
very sick and she's very frail and
fragile
can you kind of walk me through your
transformation process as an actor
whether that means you know the
physicality of it or
even i'm just curious how you master the
the breathy way of speaking
in this movie i was blown away by our
production designer nora
who just
served it up completely every single
detail
you know for an actor it was all there
the camera might never see it but it's
there and you see it
and it just i think for me it helps me
get right into it you know it's a
combination of all of it
you know when you're able to be placed
in that world when you have
the hair and makeup and all of it comes
together but it's funny that you asked
about
the breathy process and i'm sure chris
uh
one of our producers i'm sure he won't
mind if i tell this story
he told everyone how you know he's like
watching me the first day
he's watching the monitor and he asked
alex or our other producers like what is
she doing with her
voice like what is she doing with her
breath and i thought it was the funniest
thing because i'm
you know trying to tell him i'm like
crisp i'm dying
i'm on a ventilator you know i have an
oxygen tank i'm not going to be
talking perfectly normal and writing
it was just the funniest moment because
he you know
they had come to me and you know
considering me for this
and then i show up and he was sort of
like what is she doing and it's like
you're sharing the screen in this movie
with rayne wilson with
finn with jack what was it like sharing
the screen with so many
dynamic actors oh it's awesome i really
admire
people and you know geek out when i'm a
fan
i was gonna ask are you an office fan
because oh yeah i mean how could you not
be i mean he's genius
he's so talented finn was just the
sweetest
and jack i just absolutely love him
i mean he would give me hugs in the
morning and call me mom
and i always wanted a son and so
thinking like oh this is like
the kind of sun i would always want to
have i mean it's just a sweetheart
[Music]
you